[Music]
twenty-three-year-old Johanna Jones was
stoked to make it all the way to
Hollywood week on American Idol
this season of American Idol people are
taking us seriously and with that a lot
of amazing talent like talent that I
think should already be signed or about
record deals like will will have these
contestants walk in and we're like what
have you been doing like how where have
you been there was one small issue
though
johannah's boyfriend Matt couldn't be
there to cheer her on he was busy taking
his final exams if I could call him and
tell him that I got a yes
I just know he'd be so happy and so
proud of me Johanna crushed her audition
she even got a standing ovation from the
judges little did she know though the
best was yet to come
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is macro don't you hit us
[Music]
my life
[Music]
it's honestly hard to tell who was more
emotional about the surprise proposal
johanna or katy perry who literally
couldn't stop bawling seriously Katy
really couldn't stop crying
[Music]
of course she's just kidding Katy and
Orlando Bloom are very much in love I
have been spoken for me and I speak for
myself and I'm very happy you're spoken
for right now yeah girl birthday Oh
Orlando loves Katy so much he put a ring
on it on Valentine's Day things when you
know you when you're attracted to
someone it's kind of opposites attract
and so I'm looking for that balance and
maybe he's looking for that you know
multitask I'm such a multitasker
everyone's a teacher in a relationship
that's how I see it now and we've taught
each other a lot
[Music]